l'époux les entasser des animaux
agonisant qui ne peuvent plus se relever
ni se déplacer des cadavres gisant sur
un sol d'excréments une vidéo choc
réalisé par l'association l214 dans un
élevage de volailles situé dans l'yonne
des images qui laissent envoie ses
consommateurs ça me choque énormément
parce que ces animaux n'ont pas le droit
de finir comme ça on sait que les
poulets sont élevées dans certains
élevages comme ça dans des conditions
ils sont nombreux ils sont enfermés mais
là c'est atroce pour ces animaux qu'on
n'a pas le droit d'entasser vingt mille
volailles comme ça c'est pas possible ça
me choque
et puis je ne serais même pas envie de
manger de ces viandes de ces nantis les
pauvres bêtes la façon de les élever la
façon des tués pour moi cette horrible
tournée en avril dernier
ces images dévoilées conditions de vie
de volaille d'une exploitation située à
chaillé on y découvre des animaux
ramasser à la moissonneuse est assez
dans des cageots parfois avec violence
l'association l214 souhaite à travers
ses images marqué les esprits et alerter
sur les conditions de l'élevage intensif
on veut pas montrer du doigt un éleveur
en particulier c'est vraiment un système
qu'on veut remettre en
une question c'est un système c'est un
débat de société un débat public qu'on
doit avoir sur nos modes de consommation
donc oui on demande aux consommateurs de
considérer ces conditions-là de se
détourner de l'élevage intensif de
mettre de l'éthique dans leur assiette
cet élevage travaille pour le groupe duc
l'un des principaux acteurs de la
filière volaille en france sur son site
internet la marque revendique le respect
des animaux
mais suite à la diffusion de ces images
la direction de duke n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer laissant la parole à
l'interprofession volailles de chair
dans un communiqué elle dénonce les
méthodes de l'association et le
harcèlement dans ce sens de victimes les
éleveurs à quand on regarde la vidéo
effectivement ça peut choquer mais leur
moi je dis il faut faire attention parce
que les à ces associations la veulent
qu'on ne mange plus de viande et je dis
attention à la désinformation parce que
il ya des montages qui sont faits de
différentes manières et à chaque fois on
prend des images sorties de leur
contexte on met de la musique dessus et
pour moi ça ça reflète pas le travail
qui est fait par les éleveurs au
quotidien il y a un an l'association
l214 a lancé un manifeste contre
l'élevage intensif des poulets cette
campagne compte aujourd'hui près de 72
mille signatures